une piste de danse envahi par des
cowboys un bal concert organisé par
l'association cow boy advance heures de
plaisir boîte chapeau et veste sur le
dos tous sont prêts à danser les cats
est prévu pour l'occasion
au total 200 personnes réunies autour
d'une même passion
la couple
ouais c'était aux états unis j'ai vu des
gens danser écouter la musique et je me
suis dit c'est pas la même chose en
entrant donc j'ai pris des cours et puis
après j'ai créé mon association est
maintenant sont des courses fait débat
là ça fait sept ans pour la première
année l'association a fait appel à
franck silver musiciens et
professionnels de country c'est une
passion ça nous a permis de nous aussi
de joindre l'utile et l'agréable
ça fait longtemps qu'on fait de la
musique moi je suis passionné de cette
culture là depuis longtemps mais on a
réussi à joindre les
l'utile et l'agréable depuis quelques
années outre ce bal pendant l'année
l'association propose des cours de
country association de danse uniquement
mais tous ceux qui aiment la musique la
musique country exactement alors sur
toutes les formes le rockabilly le
bluegrass le outlaw donc plein de sortes
de musique country pour tous les
intéressés
le prochain bal ouvert aura lieu en mai
prochain le droit d'entrée est de 10 ans